Michael Kaufman on your book just out in
the bookstores on Poland almost the last
thing you say in the book is that you
like to thank your father for giving you
the Polish language and for infecting
you with romantic prejudices
what is it romantic prejudice well it's
a notion that grace exists in defeat and
I guess goes back to the title I talk
about mad dream saving graces the mad
dreams that Poland has been dreaming is
to join the West to be of the West to
dreams of national self self look love
liberation and for 200 years all but 18
of those to the last 200 years
Poland has been under somebody else's
domination and they protected themselves
by singing songs romantic poetry kissing
the hands of women I mean I'll give you
an example of that the it's 40 years of
Communists have controlled Poland and in
those 40 years the standards they've
tried to apply are those of some
concocted proletarian egalitarianism
where people address each other or
supposed to address each other as
citizen comrade and the Polish response
is to hark back to their past and to
kiss the hands of women instead of
calling each other citizen Condren every
Polish male kisses the hand of every
female he is acquainted with and as if
to say well thank you very much but we'd
rather deal with each other's as lords
and ladies dukes and duchesses and out
of the shipyard and ice comes a a a
worker with calluses on his hands and he
kisses the hands of women and he shakes
the foundation of communism to the point
where we now see that in its death
throes really an impotent rated the hand
kissing habit come from from the gentry
of Poland is a lot like the American
South in a sense where your traditions
were maintained not by city folk but by
a defeated rural and somewhat
impoverished aristocracy but they were
the ones to whom the rest of the nation
looked they were the class that gave
crusher Schoen Pilsudski people who came
to fight in our own revolution they were
the class that that was to protect
culture and the other classes imitate it
they didn't some what they may have
presented at different times but the
standards of behavior were were imitated
I'm I'm often I mention in there that
Poland's foremost writer of conv it's
key came to the United States some time
ago and on a visit and he couldn't
understand anything he said this is the
boom until he got to rural Virginia
where he said hey the beginning
understand sort of decaying good manners
hospitality gentility the habits of
nation and that's what I meant by
romantic prejudices how big is Poland
thirty seven million people and it's uh
39 million perhaps um it's a fairly like
the largest of the East Bloc countries
Harrison Czechoslovakia is 12 million
perhaps Hungary is 11 of Romania's 22
million it's the largest and the one
with the that the only one that once had
a glorious past there was a time when
Poland extended to Odesa polish control
extended to the Black Sea almost and
it's been whittled away ever since
what's the size compared to a state in
my hand oh I'm not sure I wish I I wish
I knew that I think it's maybe Minnesota
I think I've heard that surrounded by
what other countries well it's got
Czechoslovakia he's Germany and the
Soviet Union Sweden doesn't surround it
in but across the sea across the Baltic
not very far as we follow those
countries except Czechoslovakia have at
times invaded Poland what do most people
in the country do for a living most
because this is very hard to say most
people work for a living although one
ought to be reminded of a well known
polish phrase that the government
pretends to pay us so we pretend to work
and that has been a form of resistance
to tyranny for very very long
so there are even before the last 40
years of communism there were
disparaging remarks about Polish work of
the Germans had a term for it that too
was based in the fact that you were
working for absentee landlords to a
large extent you you didn't manifest
your patriotism by working very hard I
think we've seen since then and all
during that period that poles who
emigrated elsewhere worked very hard and
very well because they were paid very
well and because it no longer became a
matter of patriotism to sabotage
absentee landlords but what most polls
do for a living the peasantry is pry in
private hands and 85% of the peasantry
is they never nationalized it's that
aberrant a country so the farms are
small and they're productive given the
lack of inputs once they would feed
Europe now they're kept artificially to
a small basis small acreage industrial
workers are the thing that this society
this last 40 years was stressed the idea
was that that is the dominant class so
you have steel mills that don't produce
steel very well shipyards that don't
produce ships very well and coal mines
where 40% of the coal is used to extract
more coal but that class is presumed
under the old fading mythology to be the
dominant class but what poles really do
a lot of is socialize they they gather
with each other they talk about romantic
prejudices that discuss poetry they they
help each other
in fact it's funny I before I went to
Poland I thought of social life and the
American context means dating how's your
social academia whereas in Poland that's
really where you exist you exist with
your more than your family certainly
obligations to state are disparaged
your obligations to your family are well
known but sometimes cloying when you're
living three and four to a room but
obligations and poor families to your
own now people 3 and 4 people I mean
sleeping in
generations are sleeping together in the
same room and shift sometimes apartments
of quite small there's a waiting list 18
years for an apartment is not unheard of
renard to buy to have it's sort of you
get it from your factory you are then
given a permanent apartment and it's
yours and you can it's social I think
it's called social property but it's
yours and you can pass it on to your
children but it's not unheard of I've
known instances where husbands and wives
were divorced and continue to live
together bringing their respective
lovers on open to Tuesdays of Wednesdays
or whatever working out whatever
arrangements to their homes because
there was no place else for them to go
it doesn't make for four amicable living
as you can imagine conditions are harsh
not as bad as a soviet fact there's a
another joke that explains it the
busload of people training loaded people
went from what was going from Moscow to
Paris and another one was going from
Paris to Moscow and they both stopped
and Warsaw just to change water or
something and passengers got out both
sets of passengers believe they had
arrived at their destination so so from
from Moscow or so looks like parents and
parents were so looks like Moscow what's
the weather like there it's a spring is
as glorious as there is it's there
spring actually glass very little around
the beginning of May the cherry trees
blossom the strawberries aroud people
shed their clothes with abandoned
because the winters are so harsh and
grey and colorless that the
transformation from the colorless autumn
and in winter to this spring is it's not
so much at the spring itself is so
wonderful but it happens in about two
days and suddenly you've changed
temperate zones you're suddenly
confronted by color by life by vitality
and and is a I go through a every spring
normally I come to life but there it was
even greater you made a had a almost
pagan quality to it it was a and you
were entering a new time zone a new
sphere and very very lovely
the name of the book is mad dreams
saving graces published by Random House
why'd you pick random well that's it I
have a friend of David Burnham who lives
in Washington and is a investigative
reporter at The New York Times and David
had done a book go for Random House and
had worked with a splendid editor man
named Bob lumison and David had told me
what a terrific editor Bob Loomis was
what a delight it had been and and
before I went to Poland I knew I would
have a book I knew I didn't know what
the book would be so I went to several
publishers and said I've been a
correspondent in Africa and India and
Canada I've written a few books and I'd
like your would you be interested and
they all said many of them say well give
me an outline and I said I can't give
you an outline as nothing has happened
yet but I bring baggage I speak polish
my father spent nine years in the Polish
jail before the war as a as a communist
I'm coming to a country which is in a
sense roots I'm coming at a time when
solidarity is is moved underground of
after martial law and they said yes yes
yes but give me an outline and I said
but what outline what am I supposed to
outline nothing has happened they said
yeah but just a talking point then we
can talk money I thought that was
essentially dishonest I did but mr.
Lumis bob was very different and he said
look he understood that I wasn't there
to talk money I was there to I was
wanted somebody to feel engaged by my
own engagement and he did and I Midway
after I was there I did my father came
to visit me and for the first year he's
86 years old and he returned to Poland
after 50 years and I wrote a magazine
piece for the New York Times about his
return to the to a very different Poland
than the one he had left but as I said
there was much in conspiratorial Poland
that he found very familiar and
ironically familiar people in jail
hunger strikes very similar to what he
know at that point mr. Lomas offered me
a contract I wrote the book and I worked
with him and I was absolutely right I
ought to point out that last year was
his year he had
the he was the editor on Neil Sheehan
Vietnam book which won the National Book
Award he was also the editor on Paris
trout which won the other National Book
Award so he was the I think it's the
first time it's ever happened the editor
who did both fiction and nonfiction and
I was very fortunate to the work with
him one of the other things you notice
about this book besides being published
by Random House there are no footnotes
there's no pic there are no pictures and
there's no index well though the
pictures were simply and never really
much got I have pictures of myself with
some of the heroes but I I felt that
while this is my story and the story of
my father the legend did get to that
later if you like
ah it's really Poland's story and it
wasn't that I met Veloso spent time with
him I I was very careful I'm very ego
maniacal in in real life my children
will tell you and somewhat vain but I I
felt it was very important to carve
myself into the story but also carved
myself out of it it isn't there's too
much real sweeping drama there's a lot
of personal drama but I wanted to
distinguish between it and so the
pictures I thought didn't add anything
people who see the footnotes and the
index are interesting I wrote it while I
had a Guggenheim and I was at Harvard
for a year writing the book at the
Russian resources and I went with some
doubts about my own credibility here was
an academic center I was a journalist a
hack in the English context of hack nut
and I thought well what are my
credentials going to be sitting up there
with these double domes and the
surprising thing is that while I very
admiring and appreciative of the
sanctuary they provided me I ended up
with a tremendous amount of respect for
my own profession for journalism in that
it's ironic we write and it wraps fish
and you know you know that that you're
writing you're doing the best you can
but you're going to they're going to be
errors and we're not afraid of value
judgments they write academics knowing
that every mistake they make
there's going to be somebody who will
remember that and remind them of it for
the rest of their lives and their
careers so I wanted to write a
non-academic book I thought this was a
subject that was I tried to do it in
personal terms and to tell a story that
wasn't going to intimidate a reader that
was going to be user friendly if I can
that was going to tell a story the end
of communism in the center of Europe in
human terms and I intentionally left out
the footnotes and index for that reason
I can't let it pass without asking you
about being egomaniacal and somewhat
vain how do you know that I mean what
what is it that makes you say something
like that well people are talking there
are I I am I perceive from consciousness
I mean I am aware of myself in
situations I know that I am the voice
recorder I see and the fact is for 30
years I have been reported for 30 years
I have been witness to events so at
dinner table conversations sometimes I
really intend to be quiet
I intend to shut up I intend to listen
to other people but they talk about
redecorating their apartment or and I
talk about watching a murder or a trial
I mean I can talk about it and after a
while I sort of give up and I and to
protect myself from hearing somebody
tell me one you know tell me about
choosing I mean the greatest meal
they've ever had I don't know whatever
it is that that that they talk about I
tell what I've seen or what I've
experienced or what I and I don't mean
to suggest that it's somehow better than
what other people experience it just
seems to me to have more sweep and and I
don't know universal appeal sometimes
where did you get this idea that these
kind of things are more interesting and
say the best meal you've ever had I
don't know maybe that's a romantic
purchase maybe Oh
growing up as an immigrant
in New York ah what years I came to New
York 1941 there's a three year old child
from France and I went to public schools
and high schools I graduated high school
in 54 Wow in Brooklyn no Manhattan
Manhattan and an awareness of of the war
in very personal terms I mean even
before I knew there was a war I knew
that my mother was crying over letters
that she had received from somebody
these weren't very knowing that her
relatives hearing that her relatives had
died hearing the sweep again of my
father's story I think I tell him that
I'm we're returning from a a
nine-year-old child returning from
evening in Brooklyn they had taken me
along and I had heard my father and the
people we were visiting used the verb to
sit in polish in ways that I had never
heard of before
Sydnee somebody said to him how long did
you sit with him so I sat there for two
years and then was she sitting at the
nearby and and I knew in the way that a
child knows about sex before he's
actually told or something that this
meant jail prison and I used to listen
to gangbusters believed like most
American kids that bad people good
people caught bad people and put them in
jail and here was the best man I had
ever known a man who had saved me as I
wake from the furnaces of war and he had
been in jail for nine years it turned
out I asked him on the subway going home
and I said you were in prison and he
said yes he said in another place at
another time I was a a revolutionary um
and I suspect that that set a standard
as I also somewhere and I think I
mentioned that he did he set set for me
a standard of honest unattainable grace
my torment and adolescence was that how
the hell was I ever going to know how
good I was if nobody was going to pull
me off a trolley car but a gun to my
head
asked me to betray my friends and throw
me into a cell without beating me could
I withstand
hunger strikes that may have been the
motor for for the search for the
dramatic I mean in his case it was
linked to sacrifice was linked to some
messianic idealism which he today
disparages as misguided and stupid and
erroneous and absurd on the other hand
the sacrifices for real people for real
friends was something I yearned for and
I is a complete digression but I
remember a Sinan Gullah in 1975 and I
was in my hotel room I'd been a car farm
cart on for a brief period of time and a
two o'clock in the morning three guys
burst in with machineguns kicked in the
door told me to go with them this is the
MPLA and I was roused from sleep and
groggily reached for my passport to go
with them and prodding the machine guns
at me and I was aware that this was the
happiest moment of my life finally I had
been called I would now know in some
level this was a happy moment I was also
aware that this wasn't the same level of
risk that others endured but I had now
an opportunity to see how I would act
and I didn't act too bad I was stood a
day in a Angolan prison without cracking
did you grow up speaking polish at home
yeah it was the first language of any
other language besides and I spoke
French as a small child and then when we
came to the States the English sort of
crowded out the French which later
returned but the Polish remained and I
spoke only to my parents in Polish where
did you go school college I went to City
College in New York graduate school and
when did you first go to the New York
time I needed a summer job in 1959 I was
getting married and I thought I could I
walked into the New York Times off the
street and through a fortuitous
accidents got a job for $40 a week
filling pay spots and
I've stayed your first foreign
assignment was Africa I went to Nairobi
in 1975 and covered for nine months I'd
covered all of Africa from Angola and
South Africa to up to Egypt I'm not all
about the kunafa not North Africa and
then for the rest of two years I did
like Africa occasionally going to South
Africa I was there for the Cerreto riots
other countries Ottawa you're in I was
in Canada I was in India after Africa I
went to India and three years covered
the Southeast Asia South Asia and from
there to Canada for two years and then
to Poland what years were you in Poland
84 through the end of 87 the years of
solidarity went underground was 84 your
first visit to Poland I had once gone
for six days as a tourist to visit John
Darton who was one of my predecessors
and a good friend and i46 day I went to
Auschwitz I looked for houses my
grandfather built in George it was sort
of a nostalgic roots visit night I took
my children how many kids I have three
and you left the New York Times in 87 no
I'm still there I left for a year on the
Guggenheim to write the book at the end
of my polish tour I went to Harvard to
write the book and wrote it in a year's
time and returned to the New York Life
and what assignments you yeah now now I
work out of New York and hide exactly to
say what I do I I write for all the
desks for metropolitan foreign and local
I do magazine pieces well I'm sort of
treated as a I hate to say 250 I'm not
sure I'm an elder statesman but but
something as a journalism has changed so
much in the years that I've been there
it's become so much of a younger man's
and woman's profession that I am shocked
to find that I am sort of a so long I
mean I'm in tenure I'm I'm an elder
statesman what where did you physically
write this book and how I was at the
Russian Research Center I had the
Guggenheim
and I needed a place to go and I wrote
to them to Marshall Goldman at the
Russian Research Center and he said come
on and they gave me an office a very
cluttered little office which I would I
would bike from my house to the office
sit there read the paper and then try to
dredge memory and my innards for some
sort of I didn't want to write a book
that would be a rehash of my
journalistic stories from Poland I
wanted it to have another kind of
structure and again the trick was to
find out how much of myself should I put
into it and how much of others and I
think the book does have that kind of a
structure it begins before I get there
with the Declaration of martial law when
five people escape the dragnet five
people who I later came to know very
well the events of December 13 1981 were
not unlike what has happened in China
more recently um but five people some of
them well known some of them less well
known whirring dice and one in foreign
banks can foreign one in Warsaw managed
to escape the dragnet that throws all of
their colleagues into jail and that sort
of sets the tone I arrived when they are
now the underground civilization that
they have so is now sprouting there are
publishing houses there are underground
theatrical groups all of this is going
on and and I begin this voyage of
discovery in fact that too has a
connection to my father it was like when
when he was telling me the story of his
imprisonment in 1932 he was in jail in
Wolfe and serving a four-year sentence
and was thrown out of the party for
crimes of national the deviations of
Polish patriotism Communist Party
Communist Party that had been his life
and he attempted suicide slashed his
wrists and his throat he was saved and
after he came out of the hospital
was put into a cell with a man who had
been an enemy of his in the party my
father at that time had a soaring
brilliant career which collapsed at that
moment but he had been the chairman the
secretary at the age of 26 of something
called the Communist Party of the
western Ukraine anyway this man who we
was in the cell with what had been a
party enemy a hardliner a man named
Schechter and I had known this story
Schechter after the war had a son whose
name is Adam Michnik who today is the
the most articulate champion of
solidarity now the editor of the only
free newspaper independent newspaper
inside the communist bloc and Adam was
the son of this man who in that cell had
acted humanely towards my father they
exchanged poems they taught each other
songs nothing particularly much I knew
the story when I got to Poland Mick Nick
was then in jail this being a very
polish story son now is in jail as a
solidarity activists he'd been there for
for two years and six months actually in
this particular awaiting trial but
Poland being a police state but a sloppy
police state I was able to kite a
message in to Adam saying I don't know
if this means anything to you but I am
the son of Adam Calvin I am here and I
don't if it does mean anything to you I
just wanted you to know that I'm the New
York Times correspondent for what
to which he replied he smuggled a
message on say I know exactly who you
are I've heard from my father about your
father
welcome to Poland in the name of our
fathers or something and and four months
later there was an amnesty he came out
when he came out we became very quickly
very good friends
how old is he's 40 40 now he had his
40th birthday party in my house so he's
now 42 and he's brilliant and he's funny
and he's wise and stutters and tells
jokes and he's he live he lives now both
in Gdansk and in Warsaw and where's his
newspaper publish now they've this is
the solidary newspaper it's only been
it's published more so
how many copies do they have a day I
think now they're up to 40,000 they've
just started since the new agreement
that you know he's also a member of
parliament he's now been elected to
Parliament this man who I used to you
know walk in the park to talk to so that
because his house was bugged because we
were you know it's so ironic to me there
were so many people who I would have to
go to great pains to see some of them
actually put on false beards and makeup
and we would meet and now they're
sitting in Parliament it's incredible
yeah she's something totally off what
we've been talking about why does
general Jerez else kee wear sunglasses
he has a retinitis I think it's a
disease in which he's ultra sensitive to
light and it's for medical reasons has
that had any effect on him over the
years of that appearance that he has is
the stiffness there is that people have
written there's a wonderful essay
written in the underground called a man
and of course it there's two things one
he has war wounds and he does wear of
course so the stiffness is physical
secondly he is a repressed individual I
don't mean that disparagingly I mean his
what little we know of his story is
rather remarkable he's 14 years old he's
the son of a miner Gentry he has a crest
a ring he's raised as a Catholic of
believing goes to the best high school
war begins his father flees to Lithuania
he and his father and his mother they're
captured within two weeks as suspect
class by the Russians remember the
Germans invade first and the Russians
came while the Russians grabbed them and
sent them to internal Russia to a camp
we don't know exactly where and we don't
know what the circumstances were somehow
his father dies in that camp and he
walks his way out he joins the Russian
army he serves then he comes to Poland
back to Poland he works his way through
the ranks at a time when you could only
work your way if your loyalty was tested
and proved on the other hand by his own
lights he is a patriot there is polish
precedent for this Poland's and here I
go back to romantic prejudices if I may
there's a Polish romantic poet of the
19th century named Adam it's curvature
was the poet I mean
is and his stanzas are today more
important than any than any political
proclamation by any politician and mitts
Garrett wrote a poem called Conrad Valen
road and the poem tells of the Teutonic
Knights raiding Poland murdering a
village stealing a baby young child
orphan child bringing it to the order
and raising this child within the order
of the child's name is Conrad Balon rod
the child becomes he's very bright as a
tactical wizard and becomes the head of
the supporter and then the poem ends
with heat with ballon rod now the head
of the order leading his legions into
what he knows to be a Polish trap dying
at the head of his legions but at the
same time avenging the death of his
mother and father the violin rod there
are lots of arguments all through Warsaw
at one time whether was Vieira's else
Kiev Allah nor was he not is he a Polish
Patriot is he not
I think his decision to step down from
not to pursue seeking the presidency
would suggest that at the very least he
is concerned with how history will
regard him in Polish terms will he be
seen and and that's a difference between
other communist leaders who deal
essentially in power not in not in
history I mean I don't think that that
shift often bulgaria is concerned with
how history or god will will view him i
think that Yara's else key does that
that he is accountable to this whole
tradition of a polish legions of
grandfathers when when when Caspar
Weinberger called him a Russian general
in a polish uniform he bristled for
three years he wanted he wanted what
could only be described as a
satisfaction I think he would have
challenged Weinberger to a duel no his
father had died in a Russian camp he was
a pole by his lights and it
it's quite interesting how long has he
been in charge over there
well since 81 really he has came to
power just before martial law and they
ran out of who the party just became so
weak you know communist generals are not
supposed to lead communist parties
they're supposed to serve the party not
lead them the generals of sort of South
American that's and this is this is
called Bonaparte ISM this is a sin under
communism but they ran out of anybody to
give it to so he took over somebody
recently wrote let go in sa' and general
euros else key don't even speak to each
other and I saw on television in recent
days a picture of the two of them
sitting one next to each other smiling
and laughing right in the Polish
Congress I think that things are
changing I think there was no question
early on that I know of someone who met
Yaroslavsky in Moscow and Yara's else
key was just the same way that he
smouldered at Weinberger he smouldered
at Oxford and Harvard having given a
doctorate to belong so he didn't mind
the rest of it but the notion that
valensa he said to a friend of mine had
never read a book would be given an
honorary doctorate was beyond his there
was something of class snobbishness in
this after all the law says peasant
background worker and here he is this
communist leader was a general of
slightly gentrified background and I
think there was that kind of hostility I
think I'm not sure they like each other
but I think they do genuinely recognize
that they were in some kind of symbiosis
I mean the general knew enough was a
tactician and he knew that the forces
against him were greater than the ones
he commanded and he knew that what he
had to do was beat a zigzag retreat and
that's what he's done
vilasa forced him into it or the forces
behind the lungs as my friend McNeil
says this isn't socialism with a human
face this is communism with some teeth
knocked out but you have to give the
general credit for knowing that he
didn't have the troops he didn't have
the horses
and all he could do was this was a time
for a retreat with while keeping the
body count slow
he talked earlier about what the
atmosphere was in the country and how
people live and sometimes four to a room
how did you live we look very well I
mean first of all anyone with access to
dollars lives extraordinarily well the
irony of Poland it's such an Alice in
Wonderland economy that as the dollar
sinks in the rest of the world it rises
in Poland there are as you know any
number of people who get their Social
Security checks and retire to Poland
because the dollar just goes further
than 425 US dollars a month you can live
on the standard of a steel worker or in
a steel worker lives on a salary four
times greater than the doctor so I pick
a steel worker intentionally that's it's
not say that again a steel worker lives
four times better than not necessarily
live four times better but his salary is
four times greater than that of a doctor
why would anybody ever want to become a
doctor for reasons of snobbishness for
reasons of status for reasons of a
doctor can also earn a lot on the side I
mean salary is going to be some doctors
but money has lost all meaning in all
value I mean one of the problems of the
economy is that there is no consensus on
that I know a woman who cleans houses
for free Europeans and for people who
earn money outside the country and her
problem is not too little money with too
much money she earns more than she can
spend and there's no way to invest in
anything so she ends up every spry day
she takes Friday's off and she buys
carpets not Persian carpets just any
cars and she has behind her house a
little cottage which he has
floor-to-ceiling full of carpets because
that's a bank account that she's going
to leave that to her children maybe
someday those carpets will be a
commodity it's one of the few available
commodities or kilims polish carpets
they're kind of attractive they're not
that but the place is full of
absurdities like that I knew a young
girl was a senior a senior in high
school
got a job in the summer for wiping the
windshields of car
after they had gotten gas and she wore
short shorts and she was quite
attractive and she ended up getting tips
on this and I said what a terrible job
you have to get out there the fumes of
the fat she says oh no she says I make
four times as much as my father who is a
professor at the University and I make
125,000 slaughters today that's nothing
back then it was four times though
they're going right so the place is full
of anomalies absurdities and in real
life doesn't take place in an economic
matrix real life takes place over tea or
over vodka with friends conspiracy has
entered into everything as conspiracy
your friends getting anything done
involves help you don't do anything on
your own you're going to need friends
the party has its network you have your
network patronage has a kind of organic
meaning you want to get furniture well I
know a woman got a nice apartment took a
long time and she wanted to furnish it
there's one store that's so reasonable
furniture sometimes and every morning
she would get up before she went to work
go to the store and wait and see if
perhaps some Swedish style furniture was
there it took her a year and a half to
furnish her apartment and she spent more
time at the shop than she felt spent at
her job but she did it that was her
mission and she accomplished it those
are the ways people live how much
television can can people watch how many
different channels there is now simply
one channel but there is one of the
things that the underground did was it
has pioneered in video so a lot of VCRs
all over the place and there's a they
not only import them from the West but
they produce their own and one of the
great VCRs that I've seen is uh there's
a solid television actor who decided
when solidarity allowed him total
freedom after martial law he decided he
wasn't going to be he was a sort of
major personality got sick fedorov ski
federer beach and yacht SEC decided that
he wasn't going to ever again submit to
censorship
so he's going to live outside the
official economy he first he did it by
drawing cartoons and sewing them in
churches and and - solidarity activist
and then he got into making his own
videos and what he would do is he take
the tape the official news that's shown
every night at 7:30 and then
meticulously superimpose his own lips ik
versions and they were hysterical they
swept through the entire country they
were they were so funny and at one point
he he showed a beauty pageant and sort
of a bathing suit beauty pageant and he
used the music he changed the music and
he used the music of the 50s of these
these insane hymns about building steel
plants and loving tractors and building
a new tomorrow and turning in your
brother and all of that nonsense and it
just was the match was so perfect it was
terrific
how many polish Americans are there how
many Americans are there with
connections to Poland the estimates are
ten million ten million in the United
States that's what I've heard is there a
strong affinity back is right is there
traffic back and forth enormous traffic
back and forth and here in the states
what's happened is that since solidarity
there's been a new immigration so there
is a division in America between the old
emigration which came in people came in
the 20s
usually a peasant backgrounds selling
mostly where in Chicago Milwaukee
Detroit Hamtramck and where they still
congregate largely I mean one of the
things I think is true about the Polish
immigrant community is that it is less
geographically mobile than other
minority groups it is still settled
around those neighborhoods where
Greenpoint in New York for example has
been polish for four generations does it
offend you or or how what the word would
be somebody says or and can you
legitimately say oh he's polish he acts
polish is there such a thing as being
polish oh this definitely is but I mean
where this comes into play in my case is
that
I am I feel polish to some extent I am
also Jewish and there are some poles who
despite the fact that my family had had
lived in Poland for eight hundred years
or whatever who would who would say I'm
not a real Pole somehow I am NOT a real
pole for some poles that's changing a
little bit but they're all sure I think
they're just like kissing hands for some
people veneration the pious veneration
and in Catholicism or form of
Catholicism that's different than say
Irish or Italian Catholicism it's what's
the makeup in the country 98% CAF like
but their Catholicism is is less
triumphant than say Italian they are the
prodigal son in the church the one who
never truly was welcomed until now with
the Polish Pope and so there's a kind of
defensive 'no svet the pole who who
after all has been aspiring to what the
rest of europe has had for so long they
wanted their own nation their own state
they have their own nation they wanted a
nation-state just as the French have
there just as a spanish of theirs and
they'd been denied so there is a way of
behaving yes where did the Polish joke
come from I don't know I've often
wondered about that I mean there every
national when I was in South Africa
there's the von de Merville joke that
every nationality has them to the
looking down on someone I think one
aspect of it was what I mentioned
earlier about the anti work ethic as a
as what I understand it to be as a
patriotic gesture I think in our own
country the American South was seen as
slothful lazy well after the Civil War I
would imagine that that was a patriotic
gesture I mean to be lazy rather than
work hard for your Victor those who have
just conquered you makes a certain
amount of sense so I suspect that that's
one origin of the Polish Jeff but I
really don't know when was Poland most
free
seventy before 1795 you could argue that
the eighteen years before the war 1918
seventy right think of it it had
disappeared for a hundred twenty-three
years it had not it was not a political
entity then simultaneously and
miraculously three empires who shared
Poland among themselves austro-hungarian
the German and the and the Russian
Empire collapse in war in revolution
1918 Woodrow Wilson comes along and
Poland is reconstituted miraculously
after hundred 23 years and at last for
18 years and then Russia and well first
Germany invades and 1939 and two weeks
later Russia invades and again the
country is dismembered their hopes are
aroused when the war is women's and when
the Nazis are defeated but those hopes
are shattered by Yalta and now we're
living at a period where Europe is again
being reconstituted again Poland is at
the center of it in a way I think that
as the millennium approaches a new kind
of Europe is emerging one may be that
that will extend from from England to
this Russian border which would fulfill
the mad dreams that I that I use is my
title how many Soviet troops are there
in Poland there are forty thousand but
they're very invisible and they're kept
very far away no one ever sees them the
Russians forty thousand is not as many
as they've had elsewhere how big is the
Polish army Polish army is the I think
the largest but not the most probably
Sturman is the most powerful in the
block after them the Russians have never
trusted the Polish army terribly much I
mean it's it's difficult will poles
fight for Russia it's a question when
did solidarity start well and what is it
well if you officially solidarity begins
in the strikes in 1978-79 in the dying
ship yards but the strands that fed
solidarity go way way back you had the
56 uprising workers uprising in Poznan
it many streams have fed this river
there was for example before solidarity
there was a student movement the
conventional the shorthand the
description of this is that in 1968
students had a nationalistic uprising
which the then communist government used
as a anti to spurn anti-semitic crusade
against many of those students among
them some of those who were now lead
solidarity in 1970 there was a worker
uprising in 1968 during the student
uprising workers were used by the secret
police to beat up students 1970 there
was a worker uprising and Bank in which
the army shot well the troops not only
fully shot and killed people
that's Gabriel Anza his start at that
time students were impervious kept out
of it there was a cleavage between
intellectuals and workers then came 76
in 76 there was a small worker uprising
and a group of intellectuals founded
something called core the committee to
help workers and that began the
unification of these two groups two
elements the workers reached out to
student students which reached out to
workers there were this grew when the
strikes began in 78 79 there were
technical experts who could help the
workers people like Branislav uremic
mechanic who I mentioned and so you had
something that was ostensibly a labor
union but it was much more than that it
was a vehicle for human rights for
political opposition it was not unlike
the American Revolution it was lots of
people who were articulating ideas
people coming from the church from
traditions of church former communists
meek Nick wrote a book called the left
the right a dialogue I mean one of the
things that happened was people whose
traditions were in the church
anti-communist we're sitting down with
people who had been communists but were
disillusioned or had left there were
suspicions there still is suspicion
the last election this was used in to
try to defeat certain solidarity
candidates by saying hey wait a minute
he was a communist it didn't work didn't
work people have learned and out of
these many strands has come this this
movement which is today both of our
labor union I know how long it can
remain both the labor union and a
political party I think eventually it's
going to have to split sure I'm going to
mispronounce this because I've heard you
pronouncing in one way and me another
Lac will win so what is the correct
pronunciation Dec bellowing oh I'm so by
one we'll saw there's a howl there's a
kind of butcher here we're here don't
worry well it's very hard I think
writing polish names of one of the
difficulties I had in the book I
couldn't change their names but I also
knew that if you have voter Savage
Mordred modulus key they're very hard
for Americans to absorb many of those
diphthongs which are which are kind of
funny tips on how well you knowing but
also not as well as I'd like to I've met
him of course and and I'm terribly
admiring of him but I use the book in
the book I use many of his age and
younger people mostly because they're
lesser-known and also because for much
of the time I was there
Alana had a public posture that didn't
allow him to be as candid I don't say
that in a negative way he was a public
figure he was the only one standing
while the rest of them were in jail or
in hiding he was the symbol of
resistance and to say things that he may
have believed but that would be
needlessly provocative if they appeared
in the New York Times was something that
I don't think he would want or could
allow did the government of there read
the New York Times
oh they read it and they used it did
they read it immediately I mean they
have somebody I would call read it
sometimes before I I have reason to
believe that they read it before it got
to New York before my dispatchers got to
New York I mean they read it off the
wire I would telex
and at least in one instance I was
called in to be told that some response
to a story that I had filed but which
had never run with
never ran or had not run by the time I
was called into to be given a response
to it which meant that they were reading
it did you get a sense that they read
any other newspaper
oh yes The Washington Post they were in
fact the to their credit they they you
know what happened early on was when
solidarity flourished the Western press
was there and I I do not quite
understand to this day why they allowed
so many Western reports I mean after all
Czechoslovakia has almost none you can't
get into Romania then you can get in
they they make it like very difficult
for you the polls had a lot of Western
reporters I often thought to myself that
that we were the Maginot Line against
the worst case scenario but even the
Polish government felt that if the
Russians invaded well at least the New
York Times would be there to document
and so we were given a lot more freedom
I think then then certainly then in the
Soviet Union or elsewhere my colleagues
and I but then there came a time when
solidarity burst on the scene American
reporters and named British reporters
would run around to talk to all of these
strikers were in the shipyard would file
their stories Voice of America Radio
Free Europe Radio France Internationale
would translate them into Poland
within 24 hours they would be back in
Poland and a loop a news loop had been
established in which the government
played no role at all well their
Minister of well their the Minister of
Information and man named Corbin try to
break into that loop and it was very
successful
he had Tuesday night Tuesday afternoon
press conferences in which we were all
invited and he told some of the truth he
also told some lies but it was no
correspondent could not attend these
conferences because gems would be
dropped and in it he berated the press
for its coverage he pointed out
misstatements in accuracy sometimes they
were inaccurate sometimes they weren't
ah but he entered the loop and in so
doing he gained silence at the news
conference were all televised for the
whole nation
we were encouraged I felt I was
encouraged to ask as aggressive
questions as possible and in some
bizarre way it legitimized them it said
ah we are now you know look at that the
New York Times is is treating us
seriously so they're treating us
seriously nation the same thing happened
when when the Solidarity priest popular
Schmo
was murdered that was the gravest threat
that eurozone skeeze government faced
and the decision was to not only
aggressively deal with his murderers who
turned out to be for secret policeman
but to have a public trial to show some
of it on television and to allow me to I
was as the the only Polish speaking
American I think I was the only was the
only American reporter allowed into the
trial but I wasn't allowed for the whole
trial from the beginning to the end
thirty days and that's cameras would
always show me the news would show me
taking notes and this was held up as see
this was on the level this one's okay
because we've got we've got an American
journalist there and so they use it they
use it we have just a few minutes left
it's called mad dreams and saving graces
and the book looks like this published
by Random House you got another book in
you if I got another book I do I've got
thinking of three other possibilities
but I want to rest a bit now and just
tend to my journalism is it tough to
write a book
well it's tougher than I thought I don't
know I remember I remember feeling at
the time that this is pretty tough in
retrospect I look back upon it with
great pleasure I thought that year at
that at Harvard was lovely I like the
idea of bicycling to work and I love the
idea of bicycling home and working to my
tempos rather than to those of other
people's you write longhand or on a I
wrote on a on a Kawano computer on a
word processor how much does the editor
at the Random House get involved in his
case he was brilliantly
he got involved in in the beginning not
much at all in fact for the first eight
months I must confess that I I kept
saying what what's my friend burned him
on about that this guys are great editor
what's he talking about I mean I don't
get any phone calls I don't get any
feedback I don't get any any
instructions I'm just a left entirely
alone and all right I guess I don't need
it I mean I work and then at the time
the manuscript was assembled I came to
New York he had gone through it and his
instincts were so good it was it was
minimal I think his his eye for
redundancy his his instinct for
structure he also had a tabula rasa kind
of attitude he he he pretended to be a
child from Ohio who had never heard of
Poland he he he forced me into whenever
I would start getting Rococo and or a
tunned and pontifical he sort of brought
me down with very gentle questions never
never any orders the few times there's
one example I can think of a simile I I
wanted to compare poll of police in
Poland I said they're an omnipresent
pledged presence and more so and most of
the society deals with them as as a
necessary nuisance as a nuisance of
urban life
not unlike dog excrement in New York and
he said now wait a minute I don't you
could use that if you want but I think
perhaps that's a little you know you're
being smart alecky the tone is at the
tone you really want to establish but
the cops are dog doing in New York and I
realize yeah I was showing off yeah I
was trying to project something that
that's okay at a dinner party maybe but
litter would have been a better better
simile there or was it metaphor what
impact you want this to him I want
ideally as I say in there somewhere that
I want this book to pay homage to my I
want it to pay homage to my friends
make a loving gesture to my father and
to sort of trace my pay respectful
tribute to both my Jewish and my polish
roots and the impact is if I could if I
could stimulate among Americans a
recognition that there is this nation of
39 million people who are too big to be
ignored a nation too big to be ignored
in the center of Europe too honorable to
be spurned and who have a claim upon our
attentions and our and our generosity
this is the book it's called mad dream
saving graces and I'll show you the
front cover again published by Random
House and can be found in your
bookstores
thank you Michael Kaufman thank you